hi i'm going to ask some questions
because i
am going to interview them people do you
like mac world i love mac world if you
and steve jobs went into a bar
that's it that's it that's the question
what are you excited about
are you excited for mac world i'm
totally excited how excited are you i'm
a lot excited are you excited very
excited how excited
i'm not excited is that exciting enough
for you yes oh this is a great shot a
little mac world right behind there
i'm gonna head over here to moscone west
and i'm gonna accost some people
i'm gonna ask them
some questions questions so how long
have you been a mac user and for about
five years was it the best day of your
life when you switched
you know
one of the best days
you're gonna get in trouble you say
nothing about you that's one of the best
days okay i don't know
one of the best things yeah are you
excited about macworld yeah definitely
what are you most excited about the
keynote in line right behind that kid a
little bit later today which kid i don't
know that guy who's like first of mine
hi hello are you first in line yeah i am
are you excited i am excited how excited
really excited are you cold no do you
have a website i do what's your website
the iof.com
hi dan i'm justine
nice to meet you oh you have a little
little apple logo there i do so does
that mean that you like apple a little
bit a lot actually how much
like this maybe even this much i need it
oh that's not enough that's not enough
there you go that's more like did you
need you to show me how excited
like this are you like this excited
you're all the way around the world in
fact
that's pretty good answer that's very
good how excited are you
over the top i couldn't sleep for two
days okay
so what are you most excited about
well i always look at mac world as kind
of
you know we've had our christmas and
we've had our new year's eve but this is
sort of like new year's and christmas
all rolled into one
are you excited i'm excited i'm excited
my hands are like twitching
are you excited um yeah i think so what
is mac again
it's cosmetics oh that's right this is a
cosmetics
big cosmetics dimension so we're gonna
have all those crazy matte girls running
around like the crazy makeup i'm gonna
get that purple to do your eyes and
leave that eyeliner right we all have to
dress in black though